it is one of the most rural regions in
Britain and those who live here would
say it's also one of the most beautiful
tourism is big business as is
agriculture but most locals have little
support for the EU well we haven't got
the freedom of way that we should have
too many rules the brought all these
regulations and things farming did a lot
better and it's gotten really downhill
farming in this country this has been in
the EU needs to be more legislation
needs to be more control on the size of
Europe
Conservative MP Julian Smith has his
work cut out trying to persuade ordinary
Yorkshire folk of the benefits of the EU
today he is in the small town of settle
where local farmers come to stock up on
groceries I'm trying to bring across
that my party is committed to this
referendum on the EU so they will have
their say and then also to make the case
that not just in Britain
Union people want less integration they
want to take these words away about ever
closer Union either ensured a yes to EU
membership but with fewer strings
attached
some of it doesn't need to and there
could be more decisions made in London
despite the promise of reform many
reject the EU out of hand we're going to
do a number of reforms before that
referendum to make Europe more
transparency more power back to local
Parliament has has the European market
working for us people people say if we
leave it we're gonna be standing alone
and I'm really haven't really thought a
bit about people quite almost there are
hopes that the reform programme will
stem the popularity of Euroskeptic
right-wing UK what's more Julian Smith
is trying to get other EU members to see
the benefit in reforms I want Brussels
to stop its mission creep there was
always this principle of subsidiarity we
need to return to that we need to give
Parliament's national parliaments across
the EU more power to Club the
block daft proposes from the Commission
the MP already has a lot of local
businesses on his side
William Whitaker is a chocolate
manufacturer who employs large numbers
of seasonal workers from Holland and
Romania the EU has enabled him to
increase production we need a flexible
labor force because we work different
ship happens throughout the year there
are many people who might join us in
april or may work till christmas and
then actually go back to the domicile
origin and come back to three months
later and that's very flexible for us
it's what we need this manor house has
been in Euro proponent Roger tempest
--sf Amalie for thirty-one generations
he rents out a part of his property to
small businesses although he is not a
fan of EU bureaucracy he understands the
advantages of the union stability you
know in peace that you know if the next
generation and generations you know for
the future I think you know being a
powerfully sitting together to you know
avoid war you know peace is more
difficult to achieve to ward and they
say you know and I think that is that's
something personally you know above the
enterprise and all that I think it's
really important
for most people in North Yorkshire
though one thing takes precedence
drilling Smith attends the opening of a
new village shop which is fitting given
that he campaigns on an economic
platform in a global world when we're up
against the real competition is China in
the rising East South America but
actually being together in this club
does work in Britain's interests and we
have to make that case Julian Smith will
have to employ all his powers of
persuasion because the reforms he is
promising his electorate in Yorkshire
first have to be sanctioned by all
Member States in Brussels